[Musica]
d
quella che per il bruco è la fine del
mondo
per il resto del mondo è farfalla
riuscendo ad individuare le emergenze ad
analizzarle e sempre possibile trovare
un mondo di modi per risolvere in
maniera brillante quando nasce un'idea
un'innovazione il livello di conoscenza
ma soprattutto la coscienza dell'intera
umanità
fanno un balzo in avanti la mia fortuna
è di essere nato in una famiglia di
operai che per passione sono diventati
imprenditori e che si sono ingegnati per
tutta la vita
la sfortuna è stata quella di perdere
prematuramente prima a mia madre e poi
recentemente mia sorella per malattie
che l'uomo non è ancora riuscito
nonostante le tecnologie a debellare
quando mia sorella e di usa non mi
poteva più sentire le ho promesso che
avrei portato nel mondo con un grande
impegno un simbolo che lei che per lei
era molto importante la farfalla blu la
farfalla è una sintesi di meccanica di
precisione è un grande e bellissimo
costrutto della natura ma è anche un
simbolo di leggerezza un simbolo di
volatilità e di velocità
l'intensità di questa promessa mi ha
portato a incontrare a caricarmi di
energia ma porta a caricarmi d'energia e
ad incontrare nel mondo tantissime
persone ma a capire soprattutto che le
emergenze sono una grande opportunità
sono un innesco alla trasformazione un
innesco per l'uomo a cercare di capire
come modificare le proprie abitudini
le emergenze sono eventi che emergono
come dice la parola alla situazione di
relativa calma di calma apparente
esistono due concetti due tipi di
emergenze l'emergenza e lente e le
emergenze veloci oggi ci troviamo
immersi in un contesto di grande
emergenza bellissima emergenza
le dolomiti sono emerse da fondali
marini tropicali e hanno portato
migliaia di metri di quota le bellezze
di questi fondali che sia l'uomo o meno
l'artefice anche il cambiamento
climatico è un'emergenza lenta la
migrazione dei popoli
il cambio degli assetti geopolitici la
mancanza di cibo dovunque la scarsità di
acqua sono tutte emergenze
l'ente che a un certo punto diventano
veloci aumentano la propria velocità e
diventano pandemie alluvioni migrazioni
di massa terrorismo queste emergenze
sono pericolose per l'uomo soprattutto
quelle lente
l'uomo è un essere lineare a differenza
della natura che si muove con regole e
schemi matematici non lineari di solito
esponenziali siamo quindi immersi in una
grande quantità di emergenza e lente e
veloci positive negative e l'uomo da
sempre e sempre chiamato a trovare delle
soluzioni a fare in maniera di tornare a
momenti di relativa calma di calma
apparente è principalmente un tema per
visionari sono loro coloro i quali
riescono ad entrare in quella fascia di
tempo che è la fascia le di visibilità
in cui tanti piccoli eventi si
susseguono finchè non diventano
emergenze veloci i visionari gli
inventori sono coloro i quali hanno
quella sensibilità di percepire questi
segnali
facciamo un viaggio nel tempo assieme
prendiamo onnipotente ipotetica macchina
del tempo e andiamo nel 1920 a cento
anni di distanza da oggi sta infuriando
la pandemia spagnola è finita la prima
grande guerra
le scienze stanno correndo la chimica la
fisica la fisica quantistica
permetteranno di sviluppare tecnologie
negli anni futuri per produrre energia a
basso costo vedremo il cambiamento della
mobilità con l'automobile i treni gli
aeroplani vedremo l'avvento dei computer
vedremo altre guerre
vedremo il terrorismo
e inizieremo a capire che sta cambiando
qualcosa nell'ambiente che sta
succedendo qualcosa a causa dei
cambiamenti climatici e arriviamo ad
oggi nel 2020 e ci troviamo ancora in
pandemia nuovamente a distanza di cento
anni ma esiste anche in questo momento
una serie di visionari di giovani
visionari che ci dicono che viaggeremo
nello spazio che andremo a visitare
altri pianeti che viaggeremo sulla terra
con dei mezzi che non dovremo guidare ad
alta velocità che utilizzando le
tecnologie di oggi
l'intelligenza artificiale il computer
quantici potremo risolvere tante di
quelle malattie e patologie che
affliggono sicuramente tutte le nostre
famiglie
io ho preso un impegno ho preso un
impegno di portare questa farfalla nel
mondo ma è un impegno nel cercare di
trovare soluzioni radicali per emergenze
lente una in particolare la mancanza di
cibo e la riduzione della disponibilità
di acqua nel mondo sono riuscito a fare
in maniera con un gruppo di persone di
utilizzare la matematica per
l'agricoltura non in maniera analitica
ma in maniera fattiva in maniera che la
matematica possa accelerare permettere
di produrre dovunque nel mondo vegetali
e proteine per dare cibo dovunque nel
mondo teoricamente potremmo realizzare
anche qui un sistema per poter far
questo
questo l'ho fatto grazie ad aver
incontrato tante persone che mi hanno
supportato la matematica
io non sono un matematico ma la baio di
matematica e di ingegneri e questi mi
stanno supportando perché inserendo la
matematica inserendo di funzioni
esponenziali le serie numeriche come
quella di fibonacci per esempio siamo
riusciti in poco tempo a dimezzare per
esempio il tempo di crescita dei
pomodori a triplicare il tempo è venuto
a triplicare la produttività del
basilico
siamo riusciti a parità di superficie a
produrre 500 volte di più rispetto al
normale campo coltivato le emergenze ci
danno la possibilità di vedere il futuro
soprattutto quelle lente di immaginarlo
ma la vita dell'uomo è veloce e lineare
abbiamo bisogno di continuare ad
alimentare visionari e persone che
cambieranno il futuro scriveranno il
futuro inventeranno il futuro dobbiamo
fare in maniera che l'umanità non si sa
come il bruco pessimista che vede solo
alla fine del mondo ma dobbiamo
ingegnarci per fargli vedere tantissime
farfalle blu grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]